ça c'est l'hôtel auquel on arrivait
lisbonne hier aujourd'hui on va parler
de sport regardez moi ce que jules un
petit bracelet gopro pour parler de la
nouvelle heroes 8 et de la nouvelle max
donc on n'a pas grand chose à dire on va
faire du vélo pour construire pas mal je
suis habillé sportster aujourd'hui on
faire une petite balade dans les bonnes
là pour deux jours et puis après le
repos parce que new york lisbonne ya un
moment ça ça commence à tirer un petit
peu
on vient d'avoir la présentation tout de
suite de la nouvelle heroes blacks 8 que
ti guy pour tout savoir la maxe car
vraiment folle et justement alors ça
c'est cool c'est gopro qui nous a donné
un sac avec tout le matos à l'intérieur
pour pouvoir justement beau c'est donc
là que tenir la maxe au point comme ça
ça va se montrer comme ça exactement ça
c'est cool donc ça ça vient là on va se
tester on a toute une journée on va le
faire du vélo ce matin ben spies en
lisbonne cet après midi comme ça je
pourrais tout vous montrer sur le dessus
j'aime à 8 black avec les accessoires
des cards j'ai la complète ici dans une
pose du centre la maxe donc celle là on
va l'ouvrir ans à tester vous en reparle
dans quelques jours parce que pour
l'instant et son mari donc j'ai pas le
droit de vous montrer les images avant
le 22 ou le 21 juin c'est plus un petit
bonnet gopro sow corporate bonds ça ne
va pas trop le pas fut lobo est ici j'ai
pas un chat ce monde je crois pour
pouvoir la tâche et devant donc genre
plein d'image au jour d'aujourd'hui
après de la black un l'a8
là j'ai de quoi de mettre un ordinateur
je crois ouais c'est ça parle ça qui est
vraiment vraiment cool merci gopro bon
maintenant on va prendre le bus on va
faire du vélo et on va s'étoffer légende
j'ai mal aux yeux rivés malgache veut ça
j'ai des valeurs qui sont comme les
mâles de liste et l'op tion peu plus
mais je suis très très heureux mais
qu'est ce que tu ta question
j'ai attaqué je ne dis même pas que les
écouta question bonjour monsieur van
giau c'est le meilleur moment de ma vie
avant ce que je vivrai demain parce que
tous les jours sont des meilleures de ma
vie bon à partir de maintenant on va
passer la caméra principale
on va tourner à la gopro et puis on se
fera un petit débrief et là on n'est pas
dans mon arrivée je connais pas ce spot
du tout si je suis pas spécialiste non
plus de de lisbonne on veut faire du vtt
avec les différentes actions comme on va
regarder ce que ça dit là aujourd'hui
vous parle de la r8 blacks ont ce parc
dans quelques jours va tourner aussi
avec l'aeromax et à mon avis ça l'a
vraiment top et puis la partie software
lance une version bêta qui a l'air
absolument incroyable mais ça ne va pas
le 6 4 je me sens pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
regardez-moi l'état dans lequel on
arrive on dit juste dégueulasse pas si
vous en rendez bien compte comme ça
après le vtt
regardez l'état du fus juste hallucinant
il y en a de partout sortie vtt juste
énorme
et franchement très très belles
découvertes cette nouvelle coop royaux 8
parce que franchement ils ont bien
travaillé chez go pro déjà il ya un truc
il ya un truc mais un truc qui fait que
7 08
elle vaut vraiment le coup par rapport à
lass est le truc qui fait vraiment la
différence c'est que pour la tâche et
vous avez directement le système
d'accrochage qui est là ce qui fait que
vous avez qu à venir au pav de souad et
vous l'avez comme ça vous ne prenez vous
le mettez dedans et ça croyez moi ça
change toujours sur l'a7
c'est une galère absolue sur toutes les
composantes et comme ça à chaque fois on
se pète les doigts c'est à dire que pour
venir sortir votre caméra cartes et
compagnie vous devez passer le doigt là
vous tirer comme un sauvage vous pétez
un ongle au passage vous l'ouvrez vous
la sortez mais franchement chaque fois
c'est un accouchement
pas simple du tout bon là je me sens
encore plus très mal voilà et à vous
avez votre caméra et là du coup et bien
vous pouvez avoir accès ici sur votre
7,1 soit toujours là cette black
vous avez là vous avez ici accès à vos
connectique vous avez accès vous avez
accès en dessous à votre batterie à
votre carte
et ça c'est pas très pratique donc et il
faut que vous ayez ça et ça tandis
qu'avec l'autre vous avez regardez vos
petits trucs qui sont là que vous venez
ouvrir et ça c'est vraiment génial ce
qui fait que si vous voulez le mettre
sur quoi que ce soit après par amp là
dessus la voyez hop je l'aimé comme ça
je descends je prends je le fixe j'ai
pas besoin de m'embêter avec tout ce
cadre tout en plastique ce qui fait du
coup ben j'ai plus de batterie en
dessous j'ai retrouvent tous sur le côté
là c'est assez facile à ouvrir là je
vais retrouver mon usb c'est ma batterie
ma carte microsd et c'est tout c'est
vraiment y prêtera simple donc ce
système là qui paraît tout bête
et bien croyez moi ça ça change d'avis
qui fait sur le sou
vous n'avez plus rien sur le côté si
vous avez votre batterie de à côté vous
avez juste le bouton pour venir à
l'allumer pour l'éteindre et sur le
dessus vous avez un bouton on off et
c'est tout après dans le sac ils nous
ont franchement gâté on a quoi ça c'est
pour poser sur un casque ça c'est la
connectique usb usb c'est qu'est ce
qu'ils nous ont dit nous ont mis ça pour
mettre sur les vélos ça c'est un peu le
système d'attaché universel ça marche
bien je sais pas si vous avez suivi vous
aviez la fusion de la fusion c'est une
caméra à 360 degrés il fallait deux
cartes microsd à l'intérieur il y avait
un truc un petit peu lourd à mettre en
place si vous voulez pouvoir utiliser et
justement l'idée de la maxe cessé de
reprendre le principe de la fusion ont
beaucoup plus simple facilement
évitables ou on se prend pas la tête
nous on dit aujourd'hui la fusion reste
la meilleure caméra à 360 sur le marché
à moins de 1000 euros là max n'ira
peut-être pas aussi loin que la fusion
en termes de qualité d'image par contre
pour utilisation pour monsieur et madame
tout le monde enfin tout cas pour ceux
qui veulent bloquer partager sur les
réseaux sociaux facilement instagram
pouvoir éditer très facilement dans une
application
on n'en parle plus tard vous allez pas
on nous a montré le touquet ou ficib
vous et votre caméra pour naviguer à 360
avec vos doigts très facilement et vous
mettez des points clés tac
là je suis sur cette image l'attaquent
une image clé je fais tourner ma caméra
partagera donc ma caméra soit dans le
sens et vous mettez des points clés qui
vous permette effectivement de faire des
changements des changements de plans des
changements zoom dézoom en sorte qu'elle
a vraiment très très simple je la prends
je la mets comme ça
j'active hop voilà là il en train de
partir j'ai mon petit moniteur qui est
là je veux mais la région natale à 360
normalement je peux bouger est un peu
scurit on va aussi la directement dans
lisbonne
voyez on est plutôt pas mal pour que
saab est assez cool ça fait quelques
temps je vais pouvoir utiliser un
système comme ça pour différents plans
notamment des plans urbains et je suis
très content de pouvoir avoir cette
carte de pouvoir le faire je vous dirai
ce que j'en pense de mon retour très
très très très très rapidement et en
plus qui passe mon poulet climax
regarder ça vous avez espèce de gros
packaging nous ont bien dit de venir
mettre ça sur les optiques pour palais
les endommager pour pas laisser dire on
a eu un petit stick à la main de sa pour
poser sur les casques ça c'est la croche
le cas de sa dette pour aller sous l'eau
à mon avis l'emplacement qui vide la ces
pour la batterie si les promesses sont
tenues en termes de facilité
d'utilisation
ça risque de faire très très mal autre
truc qui est vraiment vraiment cool
c'est que vous avez le stick pour la
maxe vous l'ouvrez vous posez votre max
dessus et le sticky déjà complètement
invisible ce qui fait que l'on voit pas
vous vous donnez vous avez
tic dans la main ça c'est cool et ce qui
est vraiment bien c'est que c'est
complètement adaptable dans cinq
nouveaux filets 5 go pro qui sont
magnifiques avec les attaches et vous
avez tout le système pour le stick que
vous venez mettre ici vous avez des
systèmes décroche ici et en basque ne
bouge pas alors même si c'est un petit
peu de travers c'est hyper stabiliser
pour ya pas mal de modifications sur
sète hérault black de cette année par
rapport au modèle de l'année dernière je
disais déjà le côté un petit peu
purement esthétique on est tellement
craquant c'est l'heure de prendre une
petite douche on va se faire ça déjà
vous avez une caméra de 12 mégapixels à
l'avant on garde le même principe avec
un écran tactile vous pouvez venir
choisir votre mode ici photo vidéo ce
que vous voulez lorsque vous voulez
accéder à votre contenu vous partez du
bas vers le haut vous avez vos
différentes photos pouvaient venir
naviguer dedans sans aucun problème
ensuite vous redescendez et là vous
passez par le bas comme ça et là vous
avez tous vos paramètres dont le système
est très simple il ya deux boutons qui
existent en suisse est d'amasser nommé
lalla mennana des moines à cet amas de
métal au gabon m de profondeur plutôt
bien elle filme en 4k à 60 images par
seconde
ou alors au 1080p jusqu'en 240 images
par seconde autre point qui coule on
peut effectivement elle a commandé à la
voie à faire des photos en gros si vous
le voulez et faire du lac stream sur
facebook jusqu'en 1080p jusqu'à présent
c'était en 720p on monte en qualité ça
ça va plutôt dans le bon sens est ce que
nous annonce second procès qu'il avait
encore plus résistante avec un verre
gorilla glass de 2 mm contre 1,3 mm
avant ou pour la prendre les clés
étaient partout à quelques détails près
et ça devait faire au poids qui vaut
vraiment cool c'est le micro qui est
située la soul objectif qu'il en est
encore mieux capter le son on regarde
exactement le même processeur que ce
qu'on avait avant par contre toute la
partie matérielle la partie hardware
elle est différente et une toute
nouvelle batterie cette année peut
toujours utiliser les batteries qu'on
avait sur l'aéro 7 l'année dernière mais
la différence et vous aurez pas accès à
toutes les fonctionnalités donc c'est
vraiment important d'avoir la batterie
dédié à la héroïque blacks
la force de cet axiome can2go pro de 7
go pro héros 8 blacks c'est bien
évidemment le fait de pouvoir filmer
sous différents angles
mais ce qui est vachement bien c'est la
stabilisation ok on va faire plusieurs
théâtres gardé en sommeil fumant devant
la bougeotte et comme ça un peu tout
l'été pour la stabilisation voir ce que
ça dit on peut vraiment les secouer la
mère de tous les côtés c'est fait la
moue s'est stabilisée et en une
stabilisation qui encore plus nous on a
hyper smooth 2.0 avec ségo pro cette
année
l'idée c'est effectivement ce que ça
veut dire complètement stabilisé votre
image en venant couper un minimum on en
comptait un million
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh oh oui
oh
vous pouvez l'utiliser d'ailleurs dans
toutes les résolutions vous soyez en
1080p ou carrément en 4k on voit qu'il
ya un virage qui se prend du côté de nos
propres on a vraiment travaillé sur les
sportifs les vélo le ski tout ça en
connaît et cette fois-ci bon sur une
autre cible
ils y vont bien évidemment avec cette
caméra là aussi avec le modèle max
également et s'adresse aux blogueurs aux
créateurs convenu les créateurs de
contenus sont dragués de tous les côtés
je pense notamment aux fabricants de
smartphones bien évidemment au cannet on
pense aux gros boîtier mais aussi a ses
petits trucs là vous le prenez vous la
tenez à la main et vous allez pouvoir
venir vous filmez partout d'où l'idée
d'avoir mis le petit micro là d'où
l'idée de la creuse toujours plus
stabilisée prenez votre go pro vous
aller n'importe où c'est hyper smooth
vous filez très facilement et d'ailleurs
il ya tout qui arrivait sur les mods
alors les modes vous montrez vous pouvez
pas forcément le le voir comme ça ils
sont pas encore sortis on le verra qu'au
mois de décembre
c'est est ce que vous allez venir
rajouter dessus ça vient s'installer
autour de votre gopro vous devez un
petit micro qui va se situer là pour le
môle de base vous allez pouvoir ensuite
venir poser dessus un petit éclairage
led ou alors posé dessus carrément un
petit retour moniteur pour voir
exactement ce qu'on fait mais et pouvait
même faire un combo éclairage led plus
petit moniteur plus bien évidemment le
micro cayla donc du coup là vous avez un
truc qui est parfait pour venir bloguer
donc très clairement les créateurs de
contenus sont dragués sont des nouvelles
cibles de go pro même s'il l'était avant
mais la sq ont poussé beaucoup plus
affirmé il fonctionne et est qu'il coule
la times va 2.0 qui vous permettra de
faire des ralentis et des moments
choisis puis de repartir comme vous
voulez
[Musique]
aussi le live burns qui va venir
améliorer vos photos l'idée c'est que
votre caméra elle va faire une petite
vidéo de 3 secondes
vous allez pouvoir choisir la meilleure
image dans la vidéo pour avoir le
meilleur rendu photo possible toujours
de la super photo avec l'hymne prouve
hdr on va toujours plus loin au niveau
du hdr high dynamic range pour faire
tout ressortir les fonds le signal pour
tous rendant une bonne belle plage
dynamique bien complète et lorsque vous
venez film est pour même filmé jusqu'à
100 méga bits par seconde ça risque de
vous faire tout ça était très gros
fichiers en 4k 60 images par seconde 1
100 mégabits par seconde
vous risquez d'avoir tout bien bien
l'autre à tout ce qu'on voit c'est la
volonté de goprod aller toujours plus
loin toujours plus haut niveau des
performances avoir une petite action
kahn qui dominent toujours le monde de
l'action' calmes très clairement vous
adosser du timelapse vidéo de nuit pour
venir faire le show au niveau de notre
objectif ce que vous voulez sur quelque
chose de normal
la zone le mode et trois quarts
correspondrait en tout cas à ce que pour
avoir avec un smartphone soit un peu
plus ouvert le mode linéaire voyais le
plus grand le modelage ou carrément le
mode super vieux qui vient avec beaucoup
plus là là vous chopez tous qui a
partout pour vous c'est cool ça dépendra
évidemment de ce que vous voulez filmées
de ce que vous allez rechercher si vous
voulez chuté à la fois avec un
smartphone ajouté en même temps avec
votre caméra que tout prendre vous
éditez tous directement dans votre
application
quelle que soit la source que soit la
gopro soient vos smartphones ça c'est
vachement bien parce que vous n'avez pas
votre gopro vous à vos smartphones y a
un truc cool vous le foot et ensuite
vous avez chez vous vous récupérez la
gopro vous filmez d'autres plans ça vous
permet d'avoir une vidéo très complète
et ça s'est vraiment bien payé un truc
qui est vachement bien ce sont les prêts
7la vous venez cliquez ici et vous avez
tous vos paramètres de base en fait en
gros vous avez les préceptes de base
standard films en 1080p en mode large au
niveau de l'objectif 60 images par
seconde activité vous voulez un peu plus
de grand-angle à vous avez le super view
s'ouvre max 2,7 4 cm par seconde le
ralenti en 1080p à 240 images par
seconde en mode large cinéma et après
vous venez créer vous même vos propres
et 7 vous choisissez les paramètres que
vous voulez vous permet d'avoir vos
paramètres personnalisés pour y avoir
accès très rapidement donc il ya des
choses qu'on peut faire avec la gopro
héros lui qu'on pouvait pas faire avec
la gopro heroes cette black
blake dans tous les cas enfin il ya pas
mal de petites optimisations alors
l'ancien caméras l'ancien gopro il
recède blacks restent très très bonne
affaire de stabilisation était vraiment
déjà bien on améliore on va toujours
plus loin on va chercher notre site je
vous le dis les blogueurs les créateurs
de contenu et redonne une caméra qui est
toujours plus complète toujours meilleur
je passe toujours pensé vous comment on
l'a trouvée pour 7 go pro il réduit de
laquelle or non pas du design
effectivement ça reste une gaufre au ski
à l'intérieur comment vous trouvez les
images le rendu est ce que ça vous plaît
vous plaît pas qu'est ce que vous en
pensez mark et moi tout ça en bas en
commentaire et on se parle mais ces
quelques jours de la maxe là mon avis on
arrive dans le tout nouvel univers tout
autre chose les chauves ses caméras elle
va beaucoup me servir sur ce je vous
embrasse et je vous dis à demain
des bisous ciao